yes faith get a run for you a good one
quick Peter Graham should be good script
time to make myself useful huh
where do I go you need to make your way
to the agricultural division at Elysium
what the hell just saw a couple of key
side guards hassling an employee what
are they after doesn't feel right
I'm here got it be careful don't worry
Noah I got this
Kenzi well these have elapsed i
profoundly regret but they have a very
protective about this data so there's no
margin for error you understand heads up
I got plenty of commotion below an exact
quote okay deriving enforcers everywhere
what this is not looking right at all we
should abort the run let me roll with it
Noah we do not mess with Gabriel Krueger
I need the scrip it's not like I can
stop you anyway
big risk keep us updated on any changes
outside
oh uh there's someone else here not a
runner I don't like this face you should
get out of there sorry I'm checking it
out of course you are there's a whole
different set of labs here this is an
agricultural research what are they up
to
hey you don't have to do this I'm
finishing this Noah I'll be fine
you're at the mirror at the big deal on
deal with him
wait I need him alive
no I